then i started thinking about china and
i thought about the the modern day
inquisition and i wanted to get that's
happening against the muslims there in
china
where they have these uh camps where
they have like two million
uh innocent human beings i know if it's
not noah's ark it's somebody's ark
and uh what's it doing up there well
it's uh not because i question this
because i challenge it
do the muslims pay you did the muslims
pay you
i i go to the sources themselves the
people i'm criticizing
i go to their books to their documents
to their records
get their statements and most of them
talk quite frankly about it
and she said you know i'm i'm part of
the team that was working with your
biography and she said
are you aware that you're the center of
a big controversy among the editors at
the wikipedia
i said who me
how are you doing mr griffin well i'm
doing well so you're a
author filmmaker and i got turned out to
you
years ago when i watched the film that i
recommend
everybody watch it's called the truth
about cancer
global quest and you were in that film
that's a documentary with ty bollinger
you remember that i do uh you're also uh
known for in your filmmaking
industry a i believe it was called the
uh a world without cancer
right i produced that a little very low
budget documentary
back in the days when uh people were
using film strips so that was produced
as a film strip
then later we digitized it it
it's now it's played as though it's
video but nothing moves
in it it's just a bunch of still
pictures with the narration behind it
so tell us what else did i miss tell us
anything else you'd like to share with
our audience
about yourself well no nothing like if
you're talking about the books i've
written
i guess the the one that's had the
biggest play is the creature from jekyll
island
a second look at the federal reserve
before i get into health
cancer and some of these other things
that you'd like to talk about
with your show i also noticed you talk
about a lot about communism and
socialism
yes what is it are these terms you
mentioned
can you define these terms and help
educate our our audience now
on are these when you use them
interchangeably are they just
synonymous synonymously are they just
the same thing
they're not exactly the same thing uh on
the surface they're quite different
by the way are we on the show now yes we
are yes oh okay well i thought we were
just reading up to it
yeah so i have to be uh have to be more
articulate than what i say i have to
slow down and think my my thoughts
through before i start
talking so yeah um
communism socialism fascism nazism
left-wing right-wing republican democrat
um progressive liberal conservative
what are the what do these words mean
they have
internal meanings to those of us who use
them
but you can pretty well win the bar bet
by
betting on the fact that nobody else
will agree with your definition
because it's highly internalized and
there's a lot of emotion involved
pretty much in terms of what well this
is what i believe and i think
i've been called it let's say i've been
called a liberal or a conservative
so i guess i'm a conservative but this
is what i believe so
and that's internal and it's different
uh from one person to the next
and to cut to the short chase on this i
found out
back in the 1960s when i started to do
research on this i was a young guy
climbing the corporate ladder
i wasn't didn't care much about ideology
or
world affairs but i got intrigued and
that's another story but i
suddenly decided to start checking into
some of these deeper topics and
i you know i hung out at the communist
bookstore i went down there to
see what they had to say i was curious
and i
they tried to recruit me you know they
got me into study groups and
and i was serious i i wasn't serious
about becoming a communist but i wanted
to know
what these people believed so i went to
the study groups i bought a lot of their
books
and i actually read them and i found out
very quickly that a lot of the guys down
there that were
and gals they they talked about these
books but they'd never read them
and so all of a sudden i found myself as
the expert in this group
because well as griffin he's he's read
you know all all of the volume not all
of the volumes of
vladimir iliads lent in i mean he's
written
tens of thousands of pages of worth of
essays and so forth
but i've read a lot of them and i've
read you know
karl marx you know the the communist
manifesto and
das capital and then so i got a pretty
good idea what that was all about and i
was curious i
started reading some of this stuff from
the nazis i read you know mein kampf
and i read stop at mussolini wrote he
didn't write a lot but it wasn't enough
to
to see it and i read malek said and then
i
read franklin delano roosevelt and
i was reading everybody and and to make
a long story short
he uh we got to the point where i i
suddenly realized
you know this is all the same stuff
these people
actually believe the same thing except
they
they oppose each other of course they
fight wars
against each other the communists versus
the nazis in world war ii
what was that about i thought it's
because they were they were enemies over
what they believed in but no i found
out they believed exactly the same thing
in fact the nazi party is
is the national socialist party that's
what nazi stands for
it's the abbreviation of national
socialism
and and the a lot of the people who were
nazis
uh went over and became communists
and a lot of the people who were
communists went over and became nazis
they could move back and forth
and have virtually no disagreement on
anything
of principle the only thing they really
disagreed on is who was going to win
who was going to who was going to have
control over the territory
who was going to be the ruler yes it was
it was a question of
power and not ideals and boy when that
hit me
i started to take notes as to what what
were the essential elements
of this thing that they believed in and
i found out that there's a word for it
it's called collectivism
and all these words socialism kindness
fashion blah blah blah blah
are just variants of the word uh
collectivism
and the uh the constructive opposite of
collectivism
is individualism and i found out too
that prior to
world war ii those words were pretty
well
known and people used those words back
in the day i kind of got hold of some of
these old books
went back to some of the old newspapers
and magazines and the word collectivism
and individualism was
was a common word and educated people
knew what it meant
but after world war ii the word
disappeared and when i went to school
even through the university i never
heard the words and i didn't know what
they were until i started to
discover them in these old books so
having said all
of that uh i think it's important at
least for me
it seems very important to recognize
that
most of the conflict political conflict
out there
in the world including in our own little
world
like here in the united states uh we
fight like the devil to see who's gonna
who's gonna get you know control of
congress the democrats or the
republicans or the left-wing versus the
right-wing
the conservatives versus the liberals
and i discovered the heck
both of those groups essentially
believed the same thing and we were
fighting over
a non-choice we were given a non-choice
you know like even today
no point getting too close to the
present because then you start stepping
on people's toes
you're talking about people who are
their current heroes
you can talk about the dead guys but now
if you're talking about somebody you
voted for
in your lifetime all of a sudden the
people's are come to the defense
and so forth but yeah we're basically
given a choice in our modern world
what do we want to be a communist or a
nazi you know
choose upsides and wait a minute and you
come to the point where wait i don't
want either one of those but you don't
have a choice
those are the two sides and you have to
that's why people today
uh in politics today do not vote for
a candidate generally they they don't
like anybody
but they vote against somebody that
typically you hear
oh i really don't like him at all or her
but i hate the other guy
and so i'm going to vote for the lesser
of two evils and see that's the game
that's the that's the world game of
world politics today
you're always given a choice of what you
think is the lesser
of two evils but they're basically the
same evil
so i come back to the shorthand version
of the answer to your question and that
is that
i see this left wing this left
right paradigm as the analogy would be a
left wing
and a right wing on the same ugly bird
called collectivism and we've got to get
out of this
this idea that we have to choose one or
the other
because they're essentially the same
that's why we lose all the time that's
why this country's continually
been moving toward collectivism toward
totalitarianism
control from the top we've lost a
country
where where our leaders were supposed to
serve the people
now it's the people are supposed to
serve the leaders
as long as the leaders tell them it's
for your own good it's for the greater
good
of society it's for the greater good of
the greater number
and then we're supposed to oh yeah okay
we're going to do this we're going to do
give up our freedom give up our liberty
because it's the greater good
we're going to fight terrorism are we
going to fight
a pandemic or we're going to fight
climate change we're always going to
fight something that's for the
greater good for the greater number of
society but
in every step no matter where you look
at any of these crises
the solution that we are given the
choice of is we have to give up our
liberties
and pay more taxes and be more
subservient and do what we're told
and that is the trick if you can see
that then all of these um
these propaganda efforts just disappear
because you know exactly what they're
trying to do to you
before i go into talking to you about
the history
a very interesting interesting history
that you uh write about you talk about
and like i said before i got turned out
to
by that documentary the truth about
cancer a global quest
but then i saw some of the other things
that you've spoken about so i just want
to touch upon that
i heard about you talking about
communism socialism and how they're all
the same
then i started thinking about china and
i thought about the the modern day
inquisition and i wanted to get that's
happening against the muslims there in
china
where they have these uh camps where
they have like two million
uh innocent human beings i just wanted
to get your your thoughts on that
what do you think you know that's what
china be classified that's a communist
country is that right oh absolutely
they're very proud of that they
are they're self-proclaimed marxist
leninists and
communists so it's not it's not uh the
fact that we're calling them a name
or something because that's what they
call themselves yeah
are you familiar with what's what's
going on with the uber with the muslim
ubers there
yes i think i'm fairly familiar well you
see that
that again is is not so unusual because
uh
communism and fascism and any other form
of collectivism
demands total uh subservience to the
state
so that means there's no room in a
collectivist society no matter what they
call themselves
communist nazi or whatever there's no
room in such a society
for religion any religion it's not just
the muslims or the christians
or the jews or something there's no room
for religion of any kind because
when you have religion people have a
loyalty to
another set of ideals and and they look
to
their religious leaders and they look to
their holy books into their spiritual
values
for solutions to problems the state does
not tolerate that
you're supposed to be completely
subservient to the state
the state becomes the god and you have
to worship the state
so yes at the moment
the chinese are persecuting and
virtually trying to either brainwash
first get them away from their religious
beliefs
or destroy them and they did the same
thing with christians and they they will
do that with any religion
so it's not it's not really a question
of which religion it is
we have to understand that any any
theology of any kind
other than theology that the state is
the great god and we should worship
the people and we're worshiping us
ourselves you know they get in that
mind twisting kind of stuff because they
they've been told that the state
is them but it's not it's the rulers and
they're supposed to be
content with the idea that well they
voted for somebody therefore it must be
okay
now when people go and i'm sure they
will look up your name
for those who aren't familiar with you
it talks about filmmaker author
but then they threw a word in there that
really confuses some people and throws
some people off do you know what that
word
is of course yeah it's the word they
throw at anybody they wanted or one of
the words they saw
yeah i'm supposed to be a conspiracy
theorist on wikipedia threw that
on me some some years ago by the way
i've never put anything up in wikipedia
about myself
people other people had and i didn't
know was up for quite a while
and then uh how about that i'm on
wikipedia
and then one day somebody said do you
know what they're calling you on
wikipedia
no what what a conspiracy theorist so i
looked and sure enough
that's what it was well let me make a
long story short yeah i had no control
over that
the fact of the matter is this is a
little side story one of the editors
of wikipedia the editors called me
one day introduced herself and um
and she said you know i'm i'm part of
the team that was working with your
biography and she said
are you aware that you're the center of
a big controversy among the editors at
the wikipedia
i said who me no and
she said yeah she says i'm one of others
she said there's a group of us
that we read what they said about you
and we thought well
this guy is you know he's he's terrible
he's a conspiracy theorist he's got all
these
these incorrect theories and he's
probably a racist and so forth
and she said but i i started to do some
research and she said i read your books
a couple of them and she said no you're
not and
i said well thank you for that i know
i'm not and she said so we objected and
we tried to change the
narrative and from above
she said i was threatened to shut up or
they're going to take me off of my
post and she said there are some people
there at wikipedia who
who actually devote their lives to
dominate the opinions of the editors
and you don't normally get to be an
editor even if you show any kind of
open-mindedness to this sort of thing
so uh i asked her to write a book and
she said someday she will after she
retires or something when i can hardly
wait
but anyway so yeah yeah i understand and
by the way
that the reason in that case why they
uh labeled me as a conspiracy theorist
is because
not of my political beliefs but because
of my
advocacy of alternative medicine or
natural based medicine
as opposed to pharmaceutical based
medicine because i've learned that
the pharmaceutical companies and this is
not just pharmaceutical companies
by the way all the big corporations of
the world
all of them i can think i can i think
that's a fairly safe thing to say
they have they have people who are on
the payroll who do nothing but
monitor any comments that deal with
their corporation or the industry in
which they're involved
and they're actually on the payroll to
monitor that so the minute something
comes on
that is unfavorable to their reputation
or to the acceptance of their product
these guys go in there and they change
it because they're editors now
and of course they don't get paid by
wikipedia but they get paid by the
corporations which they're not supposed
to be
but it's all sort of under the table so
uh anybody who criticizes the
pharmaceutical industry in any way
or criticize not just the industry but
their products
like anybody who would criticize
vaccines today
is immediately immediately within
probably three minutes or less
somebody has picked it up their comment
and their
in their wikipedia listing they will
become a conspiracy theorist
you see automatically and you have no
control over it
there's nothing you can do about it at
least at present because the
the wikipedia has earned the reputation
of being the you know
the voice of authority and unbiased it's
anything but unbiased
totally biased and if you're talking
about mathematics or something maybe you
could trust what it says
but anything to do with profit and loss
like an industry and
health and politics or you know the big
issues
money and power the
the players who have a large stake
in money and power are are actually
controlling on
everything about that in wikipedia and
other sources as well
in there it also mentions 911 truther
is that because you questioned the
official narrative and story
of 911 well it's not because i question
this because i challenge it
i mean it's i know i go much further
than questioning and i
i don't want to push the foot around
with it to me it's
totally totally absurd i mean it's it's
like so many things once you
once you really open your eyes and start
looking objectively
you have no acts to grind you're not
protecting i don't make any money for
taking this position
in fact it it hurts me a lot i mean
people think i'm crazy and so forth
why would you want to take a position
like that when you don't benefit from it
just everything goes against you do the
muslims pay you
what did the muslims pay you
well i know they don't because they're
trying they're trying to they try to
blame islam and muslims so
you know now the truth is come coming
out and now and you know and people are
being labeled so
they might say you know maybe you're on
the muslims payroll now no no
no i'm not on anybody's paper i'm one of
those i'm one of those unemployed people
called self-employed
self-employed yeah yeah yeah so go ahead
i'm sorry well i just
that's it i just wanted to make it clear
um
yeah yeah people have a lot to lose by
doing this why do they do it well it's
because
they can't help it it's the truth i mean
we feel some of us just have this
crusader
gene that starts to vibrate and we think
well but that's not true that's not
right
now we could be wrong i'm the first to
recognize that
not only could i be wrong but i probably
am wrong on some
things i found out as i get older and
i'm quite old now
that i've changed my position on
numerous things that i
felt that i was correct on in when i was
a young man
so i'm not saying that i or anybody
and who reads my stuff and likes what i
write about saying that
this is not doctrine it's just that this
is what we believe and
if we see something that's wrong and
harmful to the human race
if it's gonna if it's gonna steal their
their their livelihood it's going to
make them
subservient to the state turn them into
slaves and
ruin their health or something like that
we get kind of ticked off by it
and we can't help it we just say well
wait a minute wait a minute i'm going to
challenge that
and of course then all the big guns are
turned on you and
all of a sudden the bullets are whizzing
by and you're called a
conspiracy theorist a racist a communist
a nazi
all of us anything a cheat a liar a
murderer
they'll throw anything at you and
unfortunately a large
number of the population will say gee i
read it in wikipedia
it must be true that's really
interesting so i commend you i mean many
people
they pretty much just follow the
mainstream narrative but you went above
and beyond
and you research and you quit you know
not just like you said questioned
you actually started to what speak out
or is there
yes i said this is what i found
attention everybody look what i found
you know this is important it affects
you
and your life your future your freedom
and
um you know so that's the way i've i've
been ever since
i got into this which was quite by
accident
i was already a young guy i was climbing
the corporate ladder i had no interest
in any of these things and
then i just started to have my eyes open
yeah so
uh finishing up on the 911 to us it's
also very sensitive because
you know when that year rolls around the
slogan never forget and we became as
muslims you know professional condemners
we're always condemning these acts you
know islam doesn't teach it you know
people might take a fringe element to do
something just like in any religion and
they try to prompt them up
as if they're you know the ones that the
exemplary example of that uh
way of life but this is what was the
catalyst
for much of the wars that were
perpetuated you know the fear and
division
and it was this event that happened
and now just it's nice to hear people
and then you have so many architects and
engineers and
others who are coming out you know and
speaking out like you are so
committed yes well and it's not because
we have any acts to grind believe me uh
i mean everybody in the world recognizes
that 911 was a horrendous
event and but the real question is
yeah who did it and what were their
motives now that
gets murky because uh it it means you
have to be open-minded
to consider some facts that you're not
going to like to hear
and if you close your mind the minute
you suspect that the fact is unpleasant
well then you if you're not very smart
because that means you'll never learn
anything
because in order to learn something
usually you have to replace
some ideas of knowledge that are not
correct
i mean i've done that a lot in my life i
remember
back in the early days in the 60s when i
caught fire on all this
i was so so inflamed with the idea that
you have to
fight communism and and by the way i
haven't changed my position on that a
bit
but i didn't realize i didn't realize
that
while we were so busy fighting you know
communism
back in the stalin's day and back in the
days
of when communism was more out in the
open
as to what it represented because we
were a lot of defectors coming out from
the soviet union and i met some of these
defectors and
and what we is communism economies look
it's taken over the world look another
country goes to communism
i didn't realize that here in the united
states
in the name of fighting communism we
were creating
essentially the same thing under another
name
we called it anti-communism number i
didn't
didn't realize in those days that there
were that this business of the right
wing and the left wing
were really the same so basically when
we
when we got into world war one even
before that
we started to adapt totalitarian
measures at home
we were asking people to give up their
liberties because we were at war
and we had to fight totalitarianism
overseas
and in the name of fighting
totalitarianism overseas
we were becoming totalitarian at home
and
and i didn't see that and if somebody
had said that to me i would have
anyone you call me or something you know
like that a knee-jerk reaction
and but no then i got to realize
oh my gosh i had been fooled or not
necessarily food i just didn't see it
that's all
so yeah we have to be willing to
challenge our own beliefs
not that we're going to change our mind
easily but
who knows facts are facts and if you're
not willing to look at the facts here
you're going to make some terrible
mistakes just one more on this term
conspiracy theorist when was this do you
know when this actually was
coined and the motive behind that
i don't really know i've heard different
versions of that and i've never
researched it
myself but i've been told that it was a
phrase that was
developed in the in the psychological
laboratories
at the cia or one of the maybe
one of the other national uh so-called
security agencies
but it was designed i've heard this i
can't
show you the documents but it sounds
logical that they
they came up with words that they could
use
to neutralize their you know opposition
and his name calling basically and if
you call
people enough nasty names and if you if
you hear it coming from
multiple sources over a long enough
period of time the average person is
going to think hmm
you know where there's where there's
smoke there's fire or
something like that you know it must be
true because i keep hearing it
and so but the short answer is i don't
really know where it was coined
but i suspect it was coined by our the
enemies of freedom
now moving on for most of your work i
i see that you really make sure that
you're quoting the right source so that
you're
really academic in your research so
because you don't want to
take any shortcuts and just not hear say
so like when we talk about
now this history that you share about
the
very interesting history can you take us
back
to how the kind of the story of the
beginnings of the
the medical institution that we have
today that you talk about
yeah actually i can that's one of the
areas i did do
some serious research on uh when i was
writing my book world without cancer
because i you can't you can't really
deal
effectively with an issue of
disease why is a disease spreading in a
time when we have modern science and
when we're spending so much money and
that was a question that came up
here we are had the war on cancer in the
united states was spending more money
on finding a cure for cancer than all
the rest of the nations of the world
combined
man there were millions and millions and
millions of dollars going out for
research and studies and so forth
and yet the rate of cancer continued to
climb and
in all we got to the point where it was
worse in the united states than any
place else in the world
in spite of all this money being spent
now i should have been smart enough
to recognize the wisdom of that old
saying follow the money
you know the more money that's being
spent on something it could it should
raise your awareness that well wait a
minute who's getting the money and
how is this going is this is this are
they pretending
to have a worthy cause as a cover for
the fact that they're just
you know protecting their own interests
or making profit at your expense
quite often unfortunately that is the
case not always but
all too often so anyway uh i got
a whiff of all that in the beginning so
i started i started to write about
cancer and it became obvious that
the reason the cost or that i won't say
that
the reason cost of cancer research and
therapy was going up
while the results were going down is
because there was corruption
just as i theorized a moment ago there
was a lot of corruption in that industry
and it was unpleasant for me to face
because i did not want to think that
the whole medical profession was not
dedicated to my best interest and my
health i discovered
no it's not i'm sorry to tell you edward
it's not
their primary goal not everybody not
individually but as an industry
the the policymakers at the top and i'll
mention in a moment who those are
uh they're they're not interested in you
you don't matter at all to them
they're interested in their own pursuits
their own in
in this case uh it's their own profit
motives and we're talking about
the the pharmaceutical industry and this
all came to
pass back in 19 starting about the turn
of the 18th century to the 19th
century 1900s
there was a a situation at that time
when there was a lot of criticism about
the quality of
medical care in america there were
people who had
you know licenses they called themselves
doctors they had their sign out
and they had no degrees they had no
professional training
there was a lot of they didn't call it
quackery in those days but that's what
we would call it today
people pretending to be doctors who were
not doctors
and so there was a lot of criticism
about that oh this is terrible what are
we going to do about it
i might add before i go on that it's
true that there were a lot of
very unscrupulous people in the medical
profession pretending to have knowledge
that they didn't have
but at the same time most people doing
this historical review forget to notice
that a lot of those people without
degrees were very good doctors
because they had learned everything they
had that they knew from their
grandmother
and their grandmother had learned a lot
from her grandmother and it was
it was hand-me-down medicine that does
not mean it's bad medicine in fact it's
very good medicine
because it's been tested and tried over
generation after generation
so there were a lot of good doctors
without official degrees but
nevertheless
that was the condition at the time and
so
the rockefellers who were heavily
invested in
the emerging medicine field
the chemical aspect of medicine not the
herbal not the natural
type of medicine but the test tube
medicine
they were heavily invested in in this
industry
because uh actually they were involved
as
cartel members with one of the largest
probably the largest cartel in the world
at that time for sure called ig farben
which came out of germany
it's ig farben i believe stood for
interesting good mineshaft farb industry
i i murdered the production
pronunciation of the german but
it stands for interesting mineshaft
i i've been told means a community of
interest
which means a cartel in english it's a
cartel
and and um
farb farb industry means the farben
industry means the dye stuffs industry
it all started out of dyes the earliest
form of chemistry as an as an industry
was to create guys
for clothing and fabrics from there it
branched into
medicines and then of course into into
munitions
how to kill people and then how to heal
them after you've blown them up and so
forth
two great industries by the way because
when you when you're interested in
in winning a war you don't care what it
costs
there's no price competition you just
you i don't care about the cost give me
the weapons
and when you're trying to save your life
it's the same thing i don't care what it
costs i want the finest guy you can find
i don't care what he charges
i'm trying to save my life from my
mother's life so
i've often mused on that fact that they
picked two good industries that have
very high profit margins
and very little price competition anyway
i'm
taking longer on this than i should let
me cut to the chase so the modern
pharmaceutical industry came
out of ig farben in germany and and
during
prior to i should say prior to world war
ii in between world war one and world
war ii um
the uh ig farming spread around the
world and went into partnership
with corporations in all countries of
the world
and they they went into partnership with
the um
standard oil of new jersey which was the
rockefeller dynasty
uh and they shared patents and processes
and um
and see germany had no natural source of
gasoline
and here was um standard oil and they
were on in the oil business
so there was each one wanted something
that the other person had
the germans wanted to get in and more
into farmers
more into uh oil and uh
rockefeller wanted to get more into
pharmaceuticals so they cross-pollinated
and all of that was in the background at
this time
when the public was concerned about the
poor quality of education so now
at this point rockefeller
funded a small group of researchers
see if i can remember their names it was
the it was a famous
report and i think it was published in
1910 or 1913
flexner report okay flexner and it was
written by
abraham flexner finally i got the names
came to the and his brother
simon flexner and now abraham was a
doctor but i don't think he practiced
medicine he just had a degree it was
probably one of those
phony degrees that we're talking about
and to make a long story short i've said
that
twice now i'll try to do better now um
they um they surveyed the united states
and yeah they documented that
there were a lot of um a a lot of people
pretending to have medical knowledge who
didn't
now now we have to do something about it
so rockefeller and
and his buddy carnegie put up a lot of
money
to pro they proposed reform medical
reform in america
and congress wasn't willing to spend a
lot of money on it so the idea
that rockefeller and um and carnegie and
through foundations tax-exempt
foundations by this time
would grant huge amounts of money to
reform education in america was seen
as an act of great philanthropy it was
wonderful
what the people didn't realize is that
both of them were planning to make a
very
nice profit out of this because they
were going to literally
change the orientation of medicine in
america and they did it
rather quickly they went around the
country and they
they found all of i've forgotten how
many but i'm going to guess there was
about six or seven or eight
fairly large institutions that taught
medicine in america
and they went to each of them and they
said look we like what you're doing
and we want to give you some money and
help you improve
your facility so you can you can have
better buildings better equipment you
can hire
higher quality teachers and so forth are
you interested
are you kidding are we interested of
course if they're interested so
when these uh when rockefeller and
carnegie mostly rockefeller
would give let's say a million dollars
to some school
why they were overjoyed now the next
step was they said
since you're receiving this money we are
hoping that you would not mind
if if you would uh consider placing on
your board of directors
someone whom we could recommend so that
we could
see how our money is being spent perhaps
you know be aware of the progress that
it's being made so so forth
it sounded very legitimate and so every
one of you oh sure who do you
who you want well they put a couple of
people on in almost every case it was
the flexners the brothers they got on
the board easily
and then they usually slip another one
in after another six months or a year
and it didn't take long before the
institutions all of these institutions
were in the control of the rockefellers
because they had captured control of
their board of directors
and even the ones who were not appointed
by the rockefellers were afraid to speak
up against them
because all the money was coming from
there and so if they rocked the boat
all of a sudden their institution would
stop getting the money so in a period of
a very few years
the great teaching institutions in
america were taken over
by the money that was given to them from
the rockefellers and the
the next thing is these guys on the
board of directors said now here's what
we're going to do
with the curricula and the curricula was
going to be changed none of this
none of this herbal medicine stuff it's
all going to be
chemistry drugs are the that's the
solution for the future
we will develop this miracle drugs we
will transform
the health of america and we will train
the best minds of america to administer
these drugs
and that is exactly what happened it
took me too long to say it i could have
said it in a couple of
minutes but the bottom line not just to
summarize that
with the investment of a few lousy
million dollars which is a lot of money
in those days
they were literally able to capture
control of the
teaching medical teaching centers of
america and they have maintained that
control to this day
most of the money research money and
development money for the universities
the medical universities today come from
these institutions the tax-exempt
foundations
whose owners have a heavy investment
interest in
the products that they are going to be
using and so the curricula has been
changed and the average doctor today
very smart guy very well intentioned
person has no
idea he's being programmed to sell to
push drugs and he knows nothing about
nutrition
most doctors will admit that their wives
know more about vitamin c
than they do and but they know a lot
about all the chemotherapy
and you know all of the psychoactive
drugs i mean they're experts on this
they're geniuses at it and that's what
happened it's as simple as that money
purchased the medical industry is this a
conspiracy theory or
is this verifiable academic facts that
people can go research and look up
that is that touches on your statement
earlier and thank you for that you said
that you've noted that everything i
write about is very well documented
and i've known from the beginning that
the stuff i'm writing about is uphill
people don't know about it they don't
want to believe it
and they're going to say ah come on that
can't be true
and so i've known everything i say i
have to document
and when i say document i don't mean
quote somebody else who has an opinion
i i go to the sources themselves the
people i'm criticizing
i go to their books to their documents
to their records
i get their statements and most of them
talk quite frankly about it
it's amazing he said they don't count on
you and i reading the stuff that they've
written
so yes it is very easy to document this
it's a matter of public record
you find all the documents you need in
any well-stocked library
now in the days ahead as we move to
digital i suppose it'll be
easier to start removing those things
but as long as they're on
books and on the shelf it's a little
more difficult to go in
and eliminate a paragraph or rewrite a
paragraph in an old book
when it's digital you can you can
rewrite the bible and still have the
cover on it it still says the
king james version but it won't be this
the same necessarily
so so grandma's old recipe that was
passed down from generation to
generation
uh that's out the window and you
mentioned is that why nutrition
is not studied by doctors in medical
school that's exactly why yeah
not only not studied but it's derived
derived i mean
derided i should say i mean most people
not just doctors
oh you're one of those health nuts oh
you take vitamins
not for me i'll take my drugs that's uh
i'll go to my doctor i got
all these meds and they're expensive i
wouldn't dream of going to
taking vitamin c or vitamin d3 haven't
vitamins you know
that's the way it is you mentioned more
people are living off cancer than
actually dying from it
that's true look at the industry
i mean you've got all of the the the
whole hospital system
i don't know what the ratio is but i
would venture that
the largest portion of money that flows
into the hospitals
and into the doctor's offices visits and
through the insurance program
surely the greater part of that is
because of just one
disease and that's cancer and um
and that's because that you know they're
paid five thousand dollars for a vial
of chemotherapy
five thousand for something that's
harmful
actually destroys your immune system in
the name of hoping to destroy the cancer
cells
it'll also destroy other cells too in
good cells
and most doctors will admit oh yeah the
whole plan of chemotherapy
is to kill the cancer just before we
kill the patient
it's a sort of nip and tuck thing you
know and so the patients who undergo
chemotherapy quite often their death
certificate may say they died of cancer
but they really died of the chemotherapy
you know it's a it's a it's an
interesting story that's all i can say
and it's it's hard you know when i was a
young guy i just
i was really hard finding it very hard
to believe
that there was this much corruption in
high places
and such important things as health
freedom you know information vital to
our
our lives our well-being our health our
longevity
our outlook on life our morality even
i why i couldn't understand that
and it so i'm very sympathetic to people
hearing this message for the first
time and um i
i don't mind if you want to call me a
conspiracy theorist that's okay but
go check me out okay and see if if you
still think so after you
read my documentation and read the words
of the people themselves who are
doing this to us because in many cases
they describe how they do it and they
boast about
how successful it is last couple
questions why do you think this history
is important for people to know
some of the well i sort of touched that
just then that it's because
the two most important things in life
are our health and our freedom
if you're free as a bird but you're
sickly and in pain and all crippled over
cannon enjoy
life what good is freedom and
if you're if you're healthy
strong as an ox and you're in a
concentration camp
as a slave what good is health you know
so those two to me represent
the two legs the cornerstone if you will
or the side stones
of being a human of having a purpose in
life and enjoying life
otherwise your humanity your life is it
means nothing
so i think i could probably talk about
this issue for a long long time but
that summarizes it it's your humanity
it's your re it's your being
your health and your freedom need to be
defended at all costs
and if uh again for someone who wants to
get in touch
all you're not selling anything your
stuff is out there it's pretty much uh
you know public record on your website
how can people
again what's the website where people
can look into some more of your work
well as i say the commercial side if you
want to actually get hold of the books
and the videos and all that stuff is um
realityzone.com but to explore the
you know the path to all of these things
we just have the ideas and the
discussions and the challenges
debates and that kind of thing going on
the starting point for that is redpill
university.org and and we open up people
to reach out to you you also uh
you you speak on uh some things i
haven't looked too much into it but
about noah
we call it noah there's something there
yeah
yeah yeah i produced a documentary some
years ago i got fascinated by
the story of noah's ark yeah you know i
i don't know i have something wrong with
my brain but i just
i'm attracted to things like this
mysteries yeah
mysteries of ancient history we can we
can we can maybe continue on in our next
conversation
in the future possibly but to see kind
of i don't know if you looked into some
of the islamic sources you know because
noah we believe
him as one of the you know great
messengers that god almighty sent you
know
uh noah moses abraham jesus peace be
upon him
peace be upon them all we and then
muhammad being the last but uh this
would be a great conversation you know
because there's a lot of commonalities
there
you know and you you would probably be
interested to see you know from there
i love that topic it's still it's still
somewhat of a mystery but
i think most of the the mystery points
have been solved
and uh and the short version is that yes
there's a there's a relic up on the
up on the side of a mountain at 7 000
foot elevation not
way up at 14th not up on mount ararat
it's 16 miles away from mount ararat but
it's there
you can walk on it you can measure it
you can see it's the relic it's the
fossilized evidence of a ship and
if it and you can see that you know if
it's not noah's ark it's somebody's ark
and uh what's it doing up there because
we both we believe we believe in this
you know in noah and this in this story
of the uh you know the great
the the flood yes well i have to say on
that
i didn't believe in it it's not that i
disbelieved i said oh maybe maybe not i
i couldn't say i believe in it i i had
no theological reason to
accept or reject it i just oh that's an
interesting story
probably not true you know but then when
i saw the physical evidence
it was so overpowering i just had to say
it's somebody's arc
and we don't know whose ark it was but
uh and that'll always be a question
until they dig up a brass plaque that
says built by noah and so
yeah the only thing there would be was a
localized instead of a worldwide that's
just the main
only difference it was more localized it
was localized
but not it was around the world but in a
narrow band because there was a flood
there was a title literally a tidal wave
that
spun around the earth at that at that
median
and it was it was well we can go into
that at some other time as to what
caused the tidal wave but i'll just
let you have a peek at it it was
interaction with i believe something
from outer space
like mars moving from one orbit to
another coming very close to earth
and you know gravitational impact on the
tides of the ocean are very strong
the moon moves the oceans up and down
quite a bit even 40 feet at bay of fundy
so you can imagine something about the
size of mars
being not as close as the moon but not
too much further out
it would have wreaked havoc on the
oceans they would have been pulled out
and they would have swirled around the
world but as you said not all around the
world
it would be as the earth is spinning the
mars is up here and the earth is
spinning
and well then you've got this this
gravitational impact on one
area so that's why there's fossil
evidence all around the world in a
certain plane
but not outside of that plane anyway
that's an interesting story
maybe for next time and if you ever if
you ever have if you ever need any
information regarding because that's
what we do we try to clear many of the
misconceptions about islam
educate people because there's a lot of
myths and also misconceptions that we
try to debunk those things and help
people have a better understanding
so we'd be a great resource for you if
you ever want us to send you anything or
any questions
we're here for you we're here for you i
thank you i appreciate that and
and i uh i'm interested in all of these
things i i feel
the only thing the thing i hate the most
about getting old
the most thing is that darn i don't have
enough time to learn everything
or even a little piece of funny i i
don't want to die
and not know something more than i do
now you know
to me that's that's the greats the great
worry about death is that i'm going to
miss something
yeah and that's why i mentioned muslim
in islam
and then just so you notice that you
like learning something islam just means
to
acquire peace by submitting yourself to
the one and only one god the same that
god that jesus moses abraham worship
that's the god we worship the creator of
the heavens and the earth and a muslim
is one who submits
is the one doing the submitting the
submitter to god that's all it is
yeah i appreciate that so i thank you
and i hope thank you
take too long to answer no no i really i
was honored to have you on the program
god bless you thank you so much
all right jd thanks for inviting me
thank you peace and if you like this
episode of the dean show
like this video share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum